[MUSIC]
Particularly in our industry,
there hasn't been a lot of big disruptive
innovation happening on the back
end on the supply chain.
[MUSIC]
We just think that the industry
is in the paradigm of
more mindlessly producing than what
consumers actually really want.
[MUSIC]
>> Come on in.
>> Thanks.
>> So this is a 3D body scanner.
[SOUND]
[MUSIC]
We have begun experimenting with new
technologies to create colors without
using water and chemical for sure.
[MUSIC]
We have materials like this.
That's really sustainable.
The white dots are actually
upcycled denim.
[MUSIC]
It creates a very tangible excitement,
I think,
when consumers can actually
put fitting products on.
We just recognize that the trifecta
of fashion, technology,
and business are all essential and
complimentary.
[MUSIC]
We as startups play
a unique role in society.
If we can't inspire change, bigger, slower
companies that have a lot of approval and
compliance processes would not even
start to think about changing.
So we play a very unique role
in pushing the envelope.
[MUSIC]